-I'm here with the drummer for
the Roots and the director of
"Summer of Soul," which is
nominated for an Academy Award
for Best Documentary Feature!
Questlove, right here,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-We're about to play charades,
but first we're going to need
some more players.
So joining my team, she stars in
the new Judd Apatow comedy
"The Bubble."
Please welcome my partner
Leslie Mann!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi. How you doing?
-Hi!
-Hi, bud.
-Hi.
-I'm so happy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
Joining Quest's team,
he is the host of the new
Netflix show "Is It Cake?"
Please welcome Mikey Day!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
Wow, my God.
How you doing, bud?
-Good.
-Good to see you. You know
Quest. You guys are partners.
-Of course.
Quest, I'm sorry in advance.
-You all know
how to play charades.
We're going to do four rounds,
30 seconds on the clock
per round.
Then the fifth round
is the showdown.
Both teams give the same clue
at the same time.
I will go first.
Leslie, come over here.
-Okay.
-This is our couch.
-You ready?
-We got this.
-Yeah. Yeah, we got a vibe.
-He told me backstage that he
doesn't know how to play.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-I know how to play.
-You don't?
This is going to be fun then.
Yeah, it's great.
Guys, what --
Four, there you go.
One person said four.
[ Laughter ]
That's confidence.
You go out, you go, "Give me" --
and one person goes "Four."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we had the best audio
in the business.
Okay, okay -- Ooh.
What?
-Uh-oh.
-Okay. I got this. We got this.
We got this. We got this.
You ready?
-Mm-hmm.
TV.
Two words.
First word.
Arm. Forearm.
[ Laughter ]
Hair.
Second word.
Marry me. Marry me!
Propose.
Will you marry me?
[ Laughter ]
Um, uh, uh, groom.
The groom. Groom.
First word or second word?
Groom.
Husband. Um, uh...
Flowers -- Bouquet!
[ Laughter ]
Bouquet of flowers. First word.
[ Buzzer ]
What?
Am I terrible at this?
-No, but "The Bachelor."
-Oh!
-Oh, my God!
-That would be hard.
-Wait, did you guys know?
-No, I didn't know.
-You said a groom?
-Oh, my God.
-I was giving you a rose!
"Will you accept the rose?"
-I forgot it was a TV show.
-I thought it was
"Runaway Bride."
[ Laughter ]
-It's a TV show!
You thought the movie
was airing on --
-I don't know.
-Oh, my God.
-Alright, alright. We got this.
We got this.
We got to start.
-Alright, what should I do?
[ Audience shouts suggestions ]
No one ever chooses nine.
I'll do nine.
-"Four!"
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. We got this.
-I don't want to let you down,
Quest.
-I give the clue first, right?
-Yep, you give the -- Yeah.
-Music. Song.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
Alright, when do we start?
[ Laughter ]
-I did it.
-Do we start now?
Do I start now?
-"Music. Song."
Alright, yes.
-You ready?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-Four words.
Oh.
-First word.
Sniff, smell.
Smells. Teen spirit.
Deodorant.
"Smells Like Teen Spirit."
-Yes.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They're professionals.
We got this.
-Do we really?
-Yeah.
-Wait, wait.
Why is Tariq yelling,
"He's my dad"?
-Okay.
-When did he become
the dad of the show?
[ Audience shouts suggestions ]
-One?
-Yes.
We got this. We got this.
-Yeah.
-You didn't see that?
-I didn't see it.
-Okay.
-Buds, we got this.
-Okay. Ready?
-Yes, I am.
-Okay.
-Movie.
-Um...
-Two words.
[ Laughter ]
"The Batman."
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-See what we do?
That's what we do.
"The Batman."
-Okay, we're tied.
-Nothing tricky.
That's a curveball 'cause no one
knows it's called "The Batman."
They think it's called "Batman."
Right? That was a curveball,
and it was meant to trick us.
But now, Mikey Day,
let's see what you got.
-I've never heard someone say it
like that.
"The Batman!"
[ Laughter ]
-I'll take two tickets --
I'll take two tickets
for "The Batman!"
-"The Batman!"
-Project!
[ Laughter ]
"The Batman."
-"The Batman!" Okay.
[ Audience shouts "eight" ]
Eight?
-Everyone says eight.
-I heard eight.
-[ Laughs ] You can show me.
You're going up against me.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ] Okay.
-Alright.
-Okay, ready?
-I'm ready.
-Quest is looking at me
intensely
and I don't want to
let him down.
-No, you won't.
-Ready?
-Yeah.
-Stop asking if he's ready.
-Television show.
Two words.
You're really intense.
First word.
[ Laughter ]
-"The Batman!"
A TV -- Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Breakdance, waves, fish.
-Ooh, it's great.
-Oh, puppets. Muppets.
[ Laughter ]
Fighter. Fight, kick.
Karate kid.
Oh, "The Karate Kid."
Karate Kid. Ah!
On Netflix! I don't know
the name of that -- Aaaaah!
Aah!
-Steal!
-Aah!
[ Buzzer ]
-"Cobra Kai!" "Cobra Kai!"
-I -- Sorry -- I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was great.
You got it though.
-I was working all last year.
I forgot the name of it.
I'm sorry.
-No, it's all good.
-Sorry.
-Now -- now, everyone,
our teams pick someone
to represent our team.
Leslie, please represent us.
-Really?
-Yes.
-Yeah, no, you go.
That was fun.
-Me?
-Yeah.
-And you both pick
the same number, and then
whoever gets it first --
this one is for 10,000 points.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
-Dollars?
-10,000 points?
-Points.
-Oh.
-Points. No dollars. Points.
-Alright.
-What do we do
with those points?
[ Audience shouts suggestions ]
-Two. Two!
-Two?
-Go for it.
-Yeah? Wow.
Alright, I'm not looking,
not looking.
-Okay. Ooh.
-Oh, interesting.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Interesting?
-I don't like
the audience reaction.
I don't like anything
that just went down.
-"Ohh!"
-"Oooh."
It's almost like, "Yeah, we're
back to 'Maury' again."
-Alright, ready.
What's the clue?
-Are we supposed to
cross like this?
-Yes. But I'm watching you both.
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
Yes, just go.
-He can do both.
-Go ahead, Mikey, what is it?
-Alright, ready?
-Yep.
-Ready?
Movie.
-Movie.
-Three words.
-"No, no, no."
-Second word.
-Heaven.
-"Don't Look Up!"
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Michael Jackson?
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-Man!
He even said it fast.
-I know!
-He didn't even say it --
He goes, "Don't Look Up!"
-"Don't Look Up!"
-'Cause I was like,
"Wait, why's he looking up?
Oh! 'Don't Look Up', okay."
-"Don't Look Up!"
-And then he did a full-on
Michael Jackson.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My thanks to Leslie Mann,
Mikey Day, Questlove!
Mikey Day and Questlove
are the champs.